the supreme court hears arguments this
morning on the new abortion law in texas
one of the significant cases that could
reshape reproductive rights all around
the country next month the high court
will consider mississippi's law banning
most abortions after 15 weeks jan
crawford is outside the supreme court
with more on this story jan a lot of
people paying very close attention to
this good morning to you well good
morning y'all really really big cases in
the texas case that's being argued today
came at the court at lightning speed of
the justices agreeing to consider it on
an expedited basis after the biden
administration and a group of abortion
providers challenged the so-called texas
heartbeat act that bans basically all
abortions in the state after about six
weeks but the focus of the case today is
on how this law is actually enforced it
gives private citizens the right to file
civil lawsuits with penalties of at
least ten thousand dollars for anyone
violating violating the law so the
question is like who can sue to
challenge the law not the bigger issue
of whether roe versus wade should be
overturned as you said that is the issue
that will be before the court exactly
one month from today the justices are
going to hear arguments december 1st in
a case that challenges mississippi's
15-week abortion ban that's the case
that's the direct challenge to roe
versus wade now you're seeing these laws
passing states across the country it is
all part of a deliberate effort to get
the issue of abortion before this newly
conservative supreme court six
conservative justices now three just
recently appointed by former president
trump and if the if the court were to
overturn roe versus wade and say states
can decide the issue of abortion what
would happen is you're going to see
these conservative-leaning states like
alabama with more restrictive laws or
bans than liberal states like new york
nate
once again our eyes on the supreme court
when it comes to abortion jan thank you